Italy was the first country in Europe to
call a national lockdown it warned its
neighbors to prepare to now its foreign
minister is warning how long it will
take before we ever return to normal
quando territory owns up to do a metal
appropriate bar a starve our condo
passagio story co doc we don't
ordinarily pin Deidre cousin veggie
poder she the lockdown a del Sol proceed
women to crois pas de rien que una cosa
quest developers to t non-soluble italia
no Patri motor on our eleanor Malita
cuando vamos commercial machine and the
vaccine could be months away at best
more than five weeks into this strict
lockdown only a few specific shops and
launderettes have been allowed to reopen
so far and even that's at regional
discretion here in lot Co nothing has
changed even those businesses can't open
til Monday
Italy's economy isn't yet on any sort of
road to recovery after intense talks a
500 billion euro Recovery Fund agreed by
EU finance ministers offers some hope
but Italy largely felt abandoned by its
European allies in the early days of
this crisis that has now prompted an
apology in the European Parliament yes
it is true that no one was really ready
for this it is also true that too many
were not there on time when Italy needed
a helping hand at the very beginning and
yes for that it is right that Europe as
a whole offers a heartfelt apology
European borders have been tightened as
countries looked inward to fight their
own domestic emergencies and Italy won't
commit to a date for resuming free
movement
yoku Minister yesterday my somos una
responsabilidad italiani residental
Estero
Resta telly pirkei in questa fossa no
adobea mophir mari el cantare Natalia
save al appreciated Anita Rihanna Lester
Ovalle port rope anchor parachuted in
astray near a Kosovo diri pretory smoke
west Astarte
my father provision is only start a
premature encuesta fasten Queen Italy's
next deadline will be nearly eight weeks
into lockdown there's no clarity yet
what will happen then just this sobering
warning the normality as we know it
simply can't resume until we have a
vaccine
Sally Lockwood Sky News Rome